and the final second eight seven six
five four three two one zero ignition
and liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket and
the dragon spacecraft on the heels of
the 50th anniversary of Apollo 11s
return to the moon we send our science
and supplies up to the International
Space Station
[Music]
but operations state long propulsions
nominal
equals magic downrange
beautiful sofa
our toiletry nominal OG max Q maximum
pressure of the rocket vehicle is
supersonic vehicle is experiencing
maximum aerodynamic pressure effect
engine chill so they begin chilling the
engine on the second stage to get it
ready to go
beautiful shot they're looking up the
tail end of the rocket
and there's the cape getting smaller and
smaller
I want approaching main engine cutoff
you'll see separation just a little bit
right after the engines to cut off
and now they go you go there it is a
separation confirmed and there goes the
booster which is coming back to land
here at the Cape I'm back ignition stage
one loose back start up and there it is
great shot of that booster coming off as
it performs the boost back burn
well you can see it clear as day this